welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
today we've got a slammin hot episode
full of memes and goofs and gasps and
laughs everything on board we have so
much to get to because today is top of
the month which has turned into one of
my favorite kind of episodic series here
here with Ella Klein in the house went
out Fila cleaners but up periods it's
kind of nice just to have an episode
where it's just me and EULA yeah there's
many guests waiting a break we need a
break I just want to get to know the
person right in front of me this whole
time you look fine
the real superstar I mean we've had some
we've had some big guests on the show
but I mean compared to a look line
yulik liners in the house they're really
all pale in comparison how are you doing
today EULA I'm good I decided not to
wear I had today this is a big day for
me so please help me be strong here we
no hat no hair comment you guys why do
you why do you want to wear a hat so bad
I don't know I just like it gives me
like more cover so I'm more like in
character and on myself Oh interesting
like so psychological you want to wear
my hat now I haven't had what I just no
hats today guys this is the real genuine
experience no family bit no close family
baby no close family day my friend isn't
no happy today our show is sponsored by
me on dates you know them you love them
to make the best Audis on earth guys
trust me more on that later and
naturebox last time we spoke about it we
ordered some snacks at this time hold
your suspense we've got the snacks
ladies and gentlemen and we're going to
eat them and all of you at home check
check on there you see we got smash
check under your seats everybody there's
a boxes won't that be the best show ever
there's just like candy peanuts under
everyone's seats maybe sometime in the
future we'll have that technology just
to beam random objects into house Amazon
will get that Amazon got him a lot
they'll start like beaming like dead
bodies and governors houses dreams on
Oh pride delivery it's like Amazon Oprah
it's the check on there you see it it's
already there I love that me and John
were thinking about doing it Amazon yeah
back when we were living in New York me
and jontron were really close to making
a show together we put so much work into
it yeah and then it just didn't really
it didn't really work out but we had one
idea for a sketch that I thought was
really terrific yeah we were all kind of
like thinking about it together there
was some funny stop it's a good [ __ ]
there it was me you I don't know if we
should say because maybe we'll still uh
it was pretty involved like I don't know
you need a big budget I don't mind
talking about but it was me you maybe
John doesn't want us whatever John come
at me Doug I'm come to LA dude come beef
with me guys ghost town dude he hasn't
made a video in 8 months he's not even a
real person anymore jontron who run this
is a crawl out you gotta come to LA
common de-spawn cast he's going to come
on people have been saying when it's
John trunk come on the pockets he's
coming on the podcast you just need to
come to LA anyway it was me John Zac aka
psychic pebbles in Gila we were all
working on developing the show together
and the sketch was like all the
different layers of services Amazon
provides yeah so it was like Amazon
Prime I was like Amazon now Amazon now
right now play on Amazon yesterday yeah
I don't remember all the details
Amazon yesterday was like they already
know what you need before you know yeah
and yesterday they already put in our
territory outside like using an existing
for getting crazier using super invasive
algorithms probably not that funny to
detect your mood Amazon already decided
what you didn't know you wanted
yesterday today and then there's like
someone creepy just following you oh
yeah there's people like spying on you
and [ __ ] like taking notes like hell of
creepy but you're just like you're cool
because they ended up selling you what
you wanted there was a part where we
like shoot stuff out of a cannon yeah oh
don't know this about funny honestly
yeah a little bit Looney tune speak to
the podcast into your reaction videos
eaten Wow
you act like you weren't involved I know
how you look
I just got reclined I just got declined
by yielded the decliner you know what I
want to talk about before we get into
the top of the month by the way top of
the month for those who don't know is
when we essentially put aside stories
videos all the top goofs throughout the
month that I think we could have a great
conversation about and we just go at it
I've got a huge list of super
interesting stuff to talk about here and
we're going to try to do it every month
I'll see I get our idea for this show
that I want to build to is like I want
it to be more of a show than a podcast
and I want to get there eventually so
like we'll have different segments say
every episode it starts with 30 minutes
where we talk about news segments and
then the guest comes on for an hour or
two hours or whatever and then they
leave and then we keep going and maybe
then maybe we take calls from you guys
right how about that yeah or we have
different segments we can have Joey
selves come in and put his down dick and
a hot dog butt or whatever like I just
want more stuff going on it's gonna be a
lot of fun that's what I'm so he's
trying to fix his image not to but Julie
you always like my already honorary
guest of this podcast I feel like so
that that's that's the concept for top
of the month that I and I think it's
going to be a lot of fun before we get
into that though there's something
that's been on my chest oh we need to
change the title of this I changed it
what do you mean it says top of the
month
oh really someone said it still sends
video again so we started it so I was
talking to Dan about that I got this
startup yeah or yeah yeah whatever
we got it but it says top of the month
now which so before we get into all
those stories there's something that
I've had on my chest for honestly a long
time and I want to talk about it get it
off my chest
do you know what it is No
[ __ ] roasted peppers Oh each section
roasted red peppers they put them on
sandwiches they put them on steaks they
put them on every [ __ ] thing
these slimy little noodles you're gonna
talk about their lawsuit roasted peppers
why would I talk about the lawsuit is
way more pressing there's way more
immediate you I mean seriously who
doesn't pick those off the sandwiches or
at least like at best you carry that I
never met anyone that likes this shot
one person alive likes that garbage
maybe bell pepper raw mine loved it
but they're like let's take a delicious
vegetable let's roast it till it's like
a soggy worm and then put it in a
sandwich let's let's can it let's put it
in the fridge so it gets even soggy ER
loses all of its flavor yeah I wanted to
taste like someone took a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your mouth and then let's put
it in a sandwich and literally nobody
like who like honestly who among us
likes roasted peppers this is nobody
this is my plea to the world please with
the roasted red peppers get the [ __ ] out
of my life I can tell you guys why he's
talking about it because maybe yesterday
or just today before I ordered a caprese
sandwich which like it's my favorite
things like the simplest best sandwich
in my opinion tomato mozzarella cheese
preach basically that's all you need and
it's already the best sandwich a little
maybe a little pesto fine if you're
lucky if you're fancy but then I got it
from this great place that we really
like to banana see no farms are you name
of Balaam name immature mobula named ma
Manistee no farms in Studio City name um
hmm well I bet it's a ok let them know
let them know the world doesn't change
you unless you own it alright so they
put be the change you want to see in the
world he listed bell peppers in that
sandwich and they ruined it it was so
bad I mean usually I'm a fat [ __ ] I'm
a gluttonous monster right and usually
I'll eat anything so he was like and
then this is what happens because I know
not to get that Garvey I'm obsessed like
I saw like Oh rest of it I'm not getting
that garbage but he or she doesn't have
the the ordering instincts that I have
so what ends up happening is I ordered
the delicious sandwich
and he listened over there not eating so
I'm like okay you want my delicious
sandwich and I'll eat your garbage and
she's like yeah obviously so I give her
my delicious sandwich and then I'm stuck
over there picking the roasted red
peppers off my [ __ ] end up eating the
sandwich with a fork unbelievable what
else I don't want to know have you want
to get that off my chest for a while so
thanks guys alright thanks for tuning in
for that I appreciate that
so next up the next thing I want to talk
about is the ghost Malone okay so a
couple days ago we posted the ghost
hunting with post Malone video and then
we removed it and I guess a lot of
people been asking why so I'll just
address it mm-hmm
basically awesome like after we finished
shooting Austin had a knife and he was
super upset at me and he started
threatening me mmm no that's not what
happened well okay first of all the main
reason was because it would just was
like off-brand it was a really shitty
video and you just wasn't I really liked
it it was YouTube was going to suggest
it to people and it doesn't really
represent the channel while it's related
this shitty but beyond that the
reception to that video was really
confusing to me everyone thought that we
all hated each other
why would I post it and like everyone
thought that Austin was mad at you I was
mad at you
you remain I wouldn't want the ELA I was
yeah okay so I just want to say like
we're never really mad at each other
especially if you see it on video we're
all joking with each other yeah people
who are saying that I was super rude and
Austin was angry at me and they never
wanted like he would never hang out
those like it was it was really
surprising because it was light-hearted
joking clearly if there was actual beef
I wouldn't have posted the video I mean
yeah I maybe I could see me that I was
annoying in it I can see that I can be
annoying but that a little bit what did
you expect you send me on a ghost hunt
okay
this skeptic I'm the [ __ ]
professional hater you guys paid me to
hate and you send me out okay Austin
built it up in it like it was this spoot
like this was like the scariest place on
earth do you know we when we were
walking around it was a beautiful trail
there were trash cans public trash cans
right there this is a beautiful public
place and so was it was not spoon I'm
not going to walk in silence for 10-15
minutes I didn't get spooked when a
[ __ ] little lizards
you know rattles by I got to keep it
real if that's annoys you I'm sorry I
think my my my opinion about it is that
it just wasn't working so the way we
presented it to people it just wasn't a
good video so they start to criticize
you know for different reasons but the
real reason is that it just didn't fit
that's why we took it down it's not like
you can't shoot it like that it just
doesn't work like the way we edit videos
on h3 I think it had to be edited down
yeah and shoot it in that because you
know there's a lot of dead air yeah
Harkness it was just so whatever into
but forget about it the reception did
kind of made me feel bad because people
were [ __ ] hatin on your boy Ethan
here I'm like what the hell did I do I
was trying to keep it real for y'all but
if you what I did I did get a little
spook towards the end yeah but I mean if
you guys want to watch me walk in
silence for 15 minutes then I can make
that video for you very easily no
problem I'll make one tonight in my room
I didn't have to be there you won't see
me at least resilence anyway a lot of
people did anyway I just get that out
there but for the most part me and
Austin are still friends very much we
love each other he's one of my dear good
friends and also people were like Austin
said Matt should I hide my mess people
were thinking too awesome because there
was a police helicopter above we were
getting spooked yeah and he says should
I have my knife because Austin being the
sweet young man a wonderful young man he
is thinks that knife so the ultimate
defense again ghosts so he brings a
knife so the [ __ ] goes down with the
ghost he could apparently stabbed the go
to the knife
so he's like should I hide my knife and
it was like oh [ __ ]
post alone smoking meth
I love you guys but goddamn alright
let's get off that [ __ ] you guys happy
now [ __ ] happy Jesus Christ
right sorry uploaded ok no I'm not real
but she's dead forever
in here there's not a bad video that's
it well here's the the most annoying
part for me is that Austin was the one
yeah telling us to upload it I won will
be finished that we're like this videos
garbage not usual maybe I watch it I
wasn't even going to copy the footage to
my computer right it took me like two
weeks until Austin really insisted to
you every day he's texted me worse than
those footage dude I want the ghost
footage so he is the one egging me on so
please go blame Austin don't care so I'm
just kidding no but ok but he's a sweet
kid he's the best but he's the one like
you'll post this footage and then I post
it and I was like even such an [ __ ]
leave poor pup's posting alone alone
he's never gonna hang out with Ethan
again he's a no I'm like [ __ ] no justice
in this world life's a struggle you guys
don't ever [ __ ] don't ever listen
life's a goddamn struggle alright so
let's get back to the show
alright now up next I'm I'm not [ __ ]
around you guys I told you this is gonna
be a meme filled episode and I'm and I
fulfill on my promise every time to you
in the last episode we had so Flo
Antonio along if you remember and we
brokered the peace between him and Joey
salads so Flo had promised to deliver
Joey for sponsored spots on his world
famous so Flo page for sharing for
shares hmm I love when they're talking
like I don't do share for share I love
hearing share for sharing a business
setting usually it's like dick pic for
dick pic something yeah it's really it's
a joke it's a joke share for share but I
love that that's actually used in
professional setting
so what I thought we do is I need to
check in with Joey I want to know if so
Flo made good on his offer so I'm going
to call him up right now and I want us
all to you know do this together Joey's
such a great
I loved him so much on the last so you
plug their me wait and see if he answers
I loved him so much man yeah he needs to
be a permanent fixture of the show he's
such a legend okay Joey can you hear me
all right you're live Dan how's it
sounding there Dan can you hear Joey oh
[ __ ] it's not working
all right I'll put you up to the mic
should I put it up to the mic so Joey
are you there yeah I'm just going on the
bedroom
oh Jesus Christ Joey what does a number
are you doing
what do you can what all right listen up
I got a check what last week as you know
getting here me going what's happening
dude yeah Gallagher's crush from the
pole okay all right oh my god
so last week we spoke to you about
brokering a peace with you and so Flo
and I just want to update I want to know
if so Flo made good on his promise to do
a share a share of a Joey salads video
he has I got oh oh nice Wow two shares
out a few more hangers already dude
that's [ __ ] bad-ass and how how did
those fare for you were those like
fruitful for you what is it what hold on
I'll heat the convo real quick because
it's the first one no problem but the
second one I told them to do it though
on the day and hit it at night uh I
think he owes you another share that's
not cool ganya no share wait would he
would he do it at night specifically
just because it's less value of course
you never know you never know what
well anyway everyone knows that everyone
knows it's not the same I texted him
Tuesday at 9:00 I go can you share this
one today I text him at 9:00 in the
morning
she texted me at 9:00 at night yeah is
now a good time I go no Kay you can live
in the morning
he goes yeah I go thing the next day I
text them at 2:00 I go did you forget
don't forget to share it he goes yeah I
can now I go thank man
and then at 5:40 IX we would be shared
it at nine o'clock you sent me to like
wow what did you say eight hours yeah
what did you say I mean I didn't say
anything I max for an extra share now
you say do you like one more night share
and I scenario thank you nitrate is
equal 1 Hornet tree right yeah I'm with
that do I need to get him on the phone
and broker another share for you now
y'all gotta go alright thanks for the
update I think that's I think that's
wonderful I'm gonna keep checking in on
you until your debt is fully paid so so
essentially you've got one and a half
shares in the end of tank out of four
yeah pretty much
I'm gonna make sure you get that that
extra nice share it's only fair oh yes
thank you all right we share that
all right Thank You Joey well alright
god bless you
take care goodbye is this the best
[ __ ] show or what this is the best
show we're talking about so Flo shares
we're talking about Joey Sal's getting a
SIL cloture I love that it took him 48
hours hey he's getting them though by
the way that's such a so for thing to do
just bounce for 40 though the night
chair you kidding me I mean the traffic
is not the same no you're right but I'm
wondering in his head is he like
crunching the numbers where he's like I
already have three shares today I'm
getting paid for Joey goes to the night
or just like [ __ ] this guy nighttime I
just think it's like well I don't want
so many people to see it so I'm just
going to do it at high it's gotta work
well that's not going to fly because and
I brokered this piece my reputations on
the line so he's getting four-day shares
yep all right we're on to you so Flo
should be alright let's move it on so
that's pretty good making good progress
here so next up this video
monitor this video shocked me you guys
so my name is Zhanna oh [ __ ]
she's wait what Mac I didn't realize
what the [ __ ] is this video
it's got like weird me and commentary oh
that's not the right one yeah that's not
it
how does this the link I got where no I
can't hear it boys let's see it
god I can't stand when people do this
computer voice man
[Music]
humongous so you guys remember humongous
it starts when he exits a town hall and
this lady is aren't what's her name's
aren't honor xarna gets in his face and
stress climb a token Mexican and that
he's killing the community and gets all
triggered when he drops his humongous
show the question I always had was what
happened in that Town Hall they got her
so triggered because she came out
immediately hating him and focused on
him so we finally have an answer to that
question yep right here we've got the
video of the town hall meeting which is
fascinating do you need me to find it
City Council let's see I don't know what
the hell I got here let me find the
original video I think this is it I was
on the subreddit name is Rudy here it is
yes so here it is guys so it starts with
Rudy giving his testimony if you can't
tell huh jr. I live in the north end
crook and you turn it up that moved here
1969 grew up on 100 turned out Marv nice
area
I am totally for a safe learning healthy
environment in the north end I pearl
precinct I believe it's a positive move
in our public safety north of the Ship
Canal I have plenty of people that
supportive of
all different backgrounds of the north
end where are they
shut up you didn't come with a mob of
people yeah you didn't come seriously
they came with a cult so the story is
that in Seattle they're thinking about
adding a new police station in the North
Precinct of the city which apparently is
our urban more dangerous drug reload
place the police station is very
expensive and humongous came here he
spent his time to come participate in
democracy which made people say they
can't do
I mean who among us spends time to go to
City Council nobody that's like someone
who really cares about their community
thank you that's true pretty much no but
I was a DJ Colin nobody nobody so he's
here spending his free time and he's
saying I think the police station is a
great idea because I trust our police
they saved my daughter well as he'll say
they took my daughter off the street
because she was addicted to heroin and
they helped me a lot and I personally
think it's a good idea which is a
complete you may disagree with them but
it's a perfectly defensible point so
let's see how they respond to him I'm
here I'm here
no no interrupting the other speakers
please I want to say this is I want to
thank the North Precinct for getting my
heroin addicted daughter off the street
and bailing her an opportunity to get
well is she white what the [ __ ] oh my
god seriously like what does that matter
what did what does that matter I don't
know it's just insane the police help my
daughter get off the street was addicted
to drug yes but was she like how is that
the first question the you are you're
gonna ask her what any interesting him
yeah like why are they blaming this guy
his experience was good is that not an
objective reality okay it's insane but I
love dislike what's the implication that
a white life has less value than a my I
do no idea why would you even ask that
I guess what okay so if I can try to
sympathize empathize with their position
is that minorities in
that precinct are targeted by police
more targeted by police so they're like
yeah of course you know they help the
white girl but here this is the great
irony this is the best part
listen to this Tina she's Latino she's
not even white humongous is is Latino
it's just so gross to even have that
absolutely and absolutely wide know
she's with like I don't know it's so
gross absolutely look there there's low
lower class white people someone who
needs to get off the street because of
drugs it doesn't matter if they're white
or not no no it doesn't but the ice I
love this twist that ends up she's
Hispanic it's like [ __ ] you hey hey hey
she is a Hispanic Latino Chicano were
proud of our heritage such a I love this
guy house is sick what a smooth
[ __ ] man he's such a graceful
oh he's a hero by the way little aside
I've been speaking to Rudy about flying
him we're going to fly him out to LA
we're going to put him in hotel we're
going to get him a guest on this podcast
I talked I've been texting with him he's
super down he's super excited so we just
need to figure out was the best time to
get him out here but honestly in my mind
I'm like what happened in there because
maybe he was inappropriate and now
seeing this he's fully vindicated fully
and completely vindicated yeah he did
nothing to deserve that treatment they
were hostile from the very beginning yes
I want to say this right now I respected
you when you see sounds like you are
coughing yes like well is that is that
not the best triggered sound ever like
that's an actual library right now
I respect you when you speak it sounds
to me like you're coughing there in the
background
my friend says
this world we live in all truly bizarre
people and things to behold oh my god
you burped like I was going crazy I bet
it's itchy my throat we have it is we
yeah I think Ethan got an allergy or
some [ __ ] Oh bye alright listen to you
that's like the social justice where
your mating call someone needs me
she's calling in reinforcements yeah
there's walk there's buses of like blue
haired what is that a massive frame so
it should Justice where he's being bused
in to support sex in this game I'm
playing there's this one game where they
do that where they scream for
reinforcements step 5 we're thinking
about we want to make a HD report where
we talk about this and all there's no so
this is like this is a great stuff this
is actually good material to it'd be
great to make a sketch where you do like
that social justice warrior made in
Colin you have like reinforcements
coming in [ __ ] should do a whole casting
call with Craigslist people there is
what they keep going several
interruption I'm going to allow him a
pretty things like what am i dealing
with yeah they're not even letting him
talk
he's just and I listened before like
well you can clearly understand why
after coming out of this he's like my
name is Hugh mangas which is honestly a
really nice way of saying [ __ ] you yeah
and to wrap up his comments I need you
to wrap up your comments though because
I'm trying to see on climate why it's my
what I have to say doesn't matter
because I live as a bi really seriously
what matters is is what everybody else
has to say we support this precinct we
think it's important investment for
public safety in the north end thank you
thank you what are they doing off-screen
Rudy's looking off the screen and like
pure shock in the sky and you can't hear
anything I can only imagine she's just
like got her badge out or something
crazy my name is Anand Joshi I am here I
can't even listen to her talk like thee
you know it's given you listen it is
like the there's so much self-importance
and delusion in her every word she says
she thinks she's walking with their King
to support blacklivesmatter I'm here to
speak to block the bunker the fact that
there is even a soul to give what is a
corrupt murderous institutionalized gang
160 million dollars is outrageous it is
mirror they are just a few bad apples
because all of the other apples around
them speak for them and protect them why
are your apples this apples metaphor is
going pretty deep apples don't wait why
are Apple speaking it's a very extended
metaphor I don't know why you gotta yell
because she's Martin Luther King she is
changing the world what are you doing
[Music]
defense is your company
alright I admit that there's problems
with the police department like a lot
mm-hmm
you know what does she want she want to
abolish the police you want to kill all
them I'm not sure I did yeah I don't
really understand the full argument here
well they're just saying don't open the
new precinct but the way she's talking
is over yeah just the way they beheld
phul the dialogue they're having is like
there's no such thing as black and white
I believe in this this is the only way
it is all cops are bad
all these talking apples which
apparently she also has this mentality
of like I'm just going to start yelling
until someone kicks me out we that's
right and then it's so she can be
oppressed too
I'm going to start disrupting this
public hearing as much as possible till
I get kicked out and then it's
oppression I love if they just left her
there close to like close the lies lock
the door and for these messes that a big
people and make them harmless this money
needs to go to people we need housing
the people need to do - people need so
her argument is that that money should
be used on other community projects
which again is a defensible fair
position but this is not a productive
debate this is just a straight-up
trigger warfare it's just so amazing -
to finally have this footage oh my god
it's so insightful because I always
wondered yeah there they are there's a
cause is Jackie is Jackie lemon here
that's Chuckie Levitt in the house so
anyway I thought that was absolutely
fascinating um looking at young Lyon
musk who's here looks so crazy well what
can we watch wait does he not have more
hair now than he did I just got
recommended this documentary about young
Elon Musk in a 1999 documentary about
millionaires and he looks horrible he
looks better now yeah
I almost creaking my god you look like a
bunny he looks like a little child in a
man's field it's seven o'clock in the
morning it's 7 o'clock in the hooding
come on musk anxiously waits for his
golden payoff his prize for paying his
dues in the valley all right when I was
Lucy yeah I just wanted to it look like
anyway I thought that was absolutely
fascinating
I I think we'll have to make a video
about that because it's just amazing and
then we're gonna have a Rudy here to
talk about it it's going to be a
wonderful full circle and by the way
Rudy's doing great I spoke to him
recently said hey Rudy how are you he
said I'm doing great thanks to you guys
all of us he's like what a [ __ ]
legend him he honestly handled himself
like and with pure class race in there
yep yep yep humongous blessed next up
living moving right along you guys maybe
have seen this on Twitter I was talking
about on Twitter Logan Paul and studio71
yesterday I was cooking breakfast and I
got a notification on my phone that our
two videos about Logan Paul got claimed
mm-hmm by studio71
and I was like uh-uh girl no you did not
can you believe this shit's still going
on I do believe it oh my god like so
here's the best part the irony of the
situation studio71 is a MCM that used to
be called collective and they did
literally the same exact thing with
prank invasion yeah except they could we
were much much smaller I think we had
like 200,000 subscribers when it
happened Oh was it um it was prank
evasion and they took it down no it was
full screen that took it down oh [ __ ]
you're right
oh god I'm right it was a whole
situation so a full screen took it down
and we were at the time with collective
and collective instead of being on our
side started to tell us that we should
actually keep it down remember wasn't
that yeah there was there were they were
like bullying us from the inside yeah
and they lied to us and we ended up
signing this contract and then they were
like sorry you signed a contract so
those guys are such leaves bad so there
was a whole situation with them so great
guy collective made ela cry yeah they
essentially I just would never taught
they're great guys seriously that was
like my first expanding like business
people and one like love them dish in
the industry I think you must hate them
but yeah I probably more than anyone
maybe my lord well what happened was we
said we'll join you but we need to be
managed which means that we're excluded
from the Content ID system because we
make reaction videos which are fair use
but if they get automatically checked
and it'll be a lot extra work for us and
so they said yes we'll give you managed
partnership and we sign and then all the
sudden were not managed anymore and they
don't tell us that so our videos start
getting claimed by the automated system
we're like yo what the [ __ ] and they're
like so and we decided that we don't
want to give you manage or there or
there was like a misunderstanding also
where apparently the guy that was
handling I didn't know what manage me is
like I tell you
I thought managed means that I'm your
manager and we're like are you working
in the same business because managed is
not that no he does and then we had a
whole conversation with the whole team
and they're like look store you got to
grow up you signed a contract so now
you're stuck that's basically what they
said to us that's exactly what they said
even worse I'm gonna war is I don't I
said okay fine you don't want to manage
our channel just release us from the
contract then because we signed your
contract them and they refused they're
like no it's time to grow up your handle
you sign a contract and ela was like
crying because we were so trapped and
our channel was so [ __ ] with them and
he's like he did it he wouldn't do it
and I I've never encountered anything
that dark and ugly and just inhuman
before and then I heard like I was I was
speaking with another person with them
and they were saying that collective
someone from collective who managed us
when we were with them was telling him
not to collaborate or work with us
because we're bad news yeah so within
the organization they're telling their
own agents not to work with us because
we're bad news the guy who made Allah
cry so moving forward the reason we're
talking about this is because
somehow maybe like a month or two later
all of a sudden they're called studio71
they changed their brand name guys and
it's all great we're not collective
anymore the slimy douche bag because
auditorium CN you know how we got out of
that contract because Ethan made a tweet
saying something about like I don't know
what you said something about how they
were handling us yeah and then as soon
as they saw the Twitter they email
that's okay we'll let you go now no way
that they said if you erase the tweet
yeah and sign this paper that says
non-disparagement then we'll let you go
and I'm like I'm not signing that that's
why I can talk about it now I've never
talked about it but it just came up now
so yeah so now they're just called
studio71 and let's just forget about
everything else they've done because
they have a new name studio71 baby it's
jazzy it's fresh the seven and the one
making arrow points to the right because
you're going to be going that way when
you join us skyrocketing in the stats so
we when we saw them claim our videos
again like we let's go mother [ __ ] it
was beautiful you can tell why this is
that this is rough anyway look anyway
they're to be fair I tweeted out to
studio71 Logan Paul and immediately they
got back to us and immediately they
resolve the situation and dropped it
there so as to be fair it's just funny
that they're still doing this [ __ ] and
I'm yeah is there no oversight like
they're just like claim yeah and if it's
and you know if it's a smaller channel
is just like your have you have no
recourse you there's nothing to do so
they end and and total fairness they
Clinton they cleared it and drop it and
like the matter of 30 minutes and Logan
Paul tweeted out you good bro I don't
know I mean I assume it was meant to be
a condescending mm-hmm you good bro
basic anyway I was like dude I recommend
checking with your network before they
start claiming videos on your bass yeah
it's so sleazy like dude if it's not a
full reload you have no right to ever do
anything with that video and I hate this
[ __ ] move of claiming it it's my
opinion is if you're going to claim it
you might as well just take it
remove it unless [ __ ] dance [ __ ]
because this claim is such a
passive-aggressive little [ __ ] s plate
because it's like you're censoring them
by removing their money but you're not
making it obvious because you're not
doing the full takedown which would show
this video was removed by collective
it's like such a bitch-ass play it's
pathetic
yeah and in this day and age after all
the [ __ ] we've been through these big
networks having [ __ ] changed one bit
anyway in fairness they resolved it
immediately but if we were a small
channel we probably would still be
getting pricked on studio71 collective
those guys are real sleaze bags let me
tell you next and I love back in the day
they're like if you remove the tweet
will let you leave the contract yeah
like what happened all of a sudden all
of sides okay okay now we've got some
leveraging really you want to do a trade
out of prison [ __ ] em seams are a
nightmare there are some good ones out
I'm not gonna I'm not going to curse all
MGM's there are there are some good ones
I'd like 97% of them what does the truth
is it really depends on the size of your
channel if you're a big channel all the
m stands are going to be pretty nice to
you yeah back then we had no one we were
smaller which is why we're so scary
because you have no one to talk to and
you're just stuck in that yeah and that
you have no way to live like they can
drop you by anything by the way is that
so [ __ ] back then yeah is that so [ __ ]
back in the day when that happened and
MCN can just click a button and drop you
regardless of anything you've signed but
if you want to leave you have to beg
them and plead with them to remove them
remove you and in that case they said
[ __ ] off no and they just have to click
a button like how horribly structure is
that ie ie oh by the way thank you to
everyone subscribing on Twitch prime
twitch prime is one of the greatest
things of all time you can give us money
for free that's right for free
I love twitch I'm not official or Amazon
I love twitch and Amazon I'm not
sponsored by Amazon but I love the [ __ ]
out of them
and here's something about twitch crime
that I didn't tell you guys before not
only can you subscribe for free every
month if you have Amazon Prime and give
us free money but I was I was on twitch
the other day and I saw that you get
little loop box when you're on prime
twitch user and you get all this [ __ ]
look at this here's another one over
watch golden lute box they give you a
loot box with a free legendary skin in
it how insane is that and you get like
free games free and game items SiC is
that you Dan
good did I just shock you Dan okay I
like some doozies so I even got our
sergeants Witcher here flipping out but
the value offers insane because you get
to subscribe for free and I was playing
the other day and I got a legendary
zenyatta
outfit that is so insane you guys anyway
I love it thank you everyone who has
supported us in that and that way I
appreciate it very much
next up these are great we're going to
get sued for talking about that why how
are we gonna get sued I'm that scared
now from losses yeah I know I mean we
literally guys everything I said was my
opinion yeah it's my experience of that
story nothing was facts okay so
definitely relax I just made it all up
okay look that's what a joke that's what
happened all right
that's not defamation if it's what
happened this is my recollection of what
happened in this case they were fair
they admit it was a mistake they even
said that it was erroneous in an email
to me and they cleared it up fast so
that was great to their credit and to
Logan's credit they cleared up very fast
I'd like to believe that they would do
that for a smaller creator I'd like to
believe that and I hope that this was a
learning experience for them going
forward to be more cautious and have
more places before claiming a video that
being said no I'm kidding I won't go
there next story this is one this hot
hot hot you guys to CNN blackmailing the
blackmailing the Nemer on reddit who
made the Trump wrestling the CNN logo
this should blew my socks off you
before your socks off I mean I was just
truly shocked by this story let me pull
it up so as you guys probably know it
was everywhere in the media Trump
tweeted out this really obscene let me
see if I can find it I want to show you
guys where is it not there no it's just
a picture of it we trade Trump CNN
Wrestling gift I mean in case you
haven't seen it let me let me show it to
you
here it is
so Trump tweeted out this gif steve-o
said you bet I'm alright thanks for
checking I mean let me check on steve-o
before the show started we were watching
steve-o had a livestream on Instagram
and he was like his face was all burned
yeah and we were like what the [ __ ]
happen to steve-o but anyway he said
he's alright god bless you man [ __ ] you
know um what's his gift how do you find
gifts they want not to find gifts at a
gifts work does anyone know how to work
it
here we go hello Internet hmm well I
ever want to have sinned it probably
anyway wait I gotta find this is
ridiculous what the [ __ ] how hard is it
to get a gift I think those are it's
supposed to work it's not though this is
just an image
here it is I think well this is
embarrassing that I can't get this knock
DNG oh my god so give the give the
preface you let me see someone found it
can you tell the backstory while I look
for this the backstory yeah so um Donald
Trump the President of the United States
of America tweeted on his Twitter its
Dylan as to it I think I'm getting there
I'm okay he found this great meme it was
a gift and he just tweeted it out could
I have anything I don't know why I
searched and I can't find it
how did you find it so fast someone link
okay here it is for the holiday
Christ I here is [ __ ] me hi
all right about to have a panic attack
good right here's the [ __ ] gift for
Christ's sake so he tweets this out
which says fraud News CNN fnn fake news
network all right I'm going to open it
clearly avert has six hundred thousand
legs three hundred fifty thousand
retweets clearly and it depicts him from
the wrestling days when he tackled Vince
McMahon and punched him in the face may
put CNN logo on Vince McMahon's face
clearly a very distasteful thing for the
President of the United States to tweet
out clearly a very inappropriate thing
but a bit of a meme to not I mean it's
kind of a an interesting time when a
sitting president can tweet something
like this out okay
so CNN got super butthurt about it but
when it happened I'm like cNN has the
high ground now like they'd just be like
that was super unprofessional you the
president grow up and they move on but
that's not what they did they were in
the high ground in my opinion I was like
you know
good for them now look at now look at
this ship how CNN found the reddit user
behind the Trump wrestling gift so they
start digging into where this gif
originated and they says to the kid let
me pull this article open it's so weird
because I just don't understand why how
is the guy related like why does it
matter who is the guy who made it so
this is this is yeah so they says CNN is
not publishing his name they says his
reddit account Han [ __ ] solo there's
something playing in the background oh
this is [ __ ] odd yeah because he's a
private citizen who has issued an
extensive statement of apology showed
his remorse by saying he was taking it
down all the spending post and because
he said he is not going to repeat this
ugly behavior on social media again in
addition he said his statement could
serve as an example to others not to do
the same so they get a hold of this guy
and they make him apologize for making a
[ __ ] meet like let's okay let's get
over the daxing that they says they says
CNN reserves the right to publish his
identity should any of that change what
I don't understand it doesn't work for
the president he just made a meme on the
Internet
it's so pathetic it's so pathetic when I
read this I'm like I can't be
understanding this right yeah an ad when
after a Reddit user for making a meme
who okay before the president tweeted
this out it was completely innocent so
like how was he how was he responsible
for the president he doesn't work for
the president and then they make him
publish this pathetic apology listen
what they says about it he showed
remorse
by taking it down and he said he's not
going to repeat this ugly behavior again
on social media it's a [ __ ] silly gif
and then they start talking about how
you made racist post and stuff like the
same thing that happened we can bond
right like why are you doing it doesn't
even matter who the person is why I even
start going there it's not relevant at
all it's so pathetic
and like before this I was kind of
defending sin and the way the president
treats CNN I think is completely
unprofessional unwarranted but after
this I'm like this is so pathetic
it's just a guy on the internet making a
joke and now all the sudden he's on
trial like who cares if he's a racist
piece of [ __ ] it's just a meme like I
don't see why he should be on trial at
all yeah if anything judged the
president he's the one who shared the
gift but the guy who made it it's like
like he was posting racist comments and
jokes on I'm going to hell for this
which if you guys know anything about
that subreddit it's there and it
celebrates really horrible things and
really horrible behavior as like a meta
joke whatever if you're offended by that
whatever I'm not here to judge that
content well what it can even if it is
full-on racist disgusting person yeah
what does it matter
doesn't matter he doesn't Trump didn't
Commission him to make it I was so blown
away by this you guys I I'm like man I
can't believe what the shoes come to and
they like stood by it they put it on the
front page proudly and I'm like CNN is
blackmailing someone who made a meme
because it I'm just I just in shock
next story so now now everyone's making
CNN memes and honestly rightfully so
they barked up the wrong tree I can't
believe that they thought that was a
good look for them they have the high
ground just be like now super
unprofessional mr. president yeah we're
going to keep doing the news to like
this but hurt like soccer mom does that
make sense
they're butthurt soccer mom what's a
what is this all come online well a
soccer mom there's there's somewhere in
there it makes sense okay somebody think
about that and let me know how it makes
sense all right let's move it on that
was really shocking to me though I
couldn't believe that [ __ ]
alright what else we got
Ellen gasps caught stealing we have a
lot of shoes she was down here oh my god
we have so much stuff you guys there yet
Lucas your coab yuck I wish here's a
great one one of the top a real top of
the month for you so Ellen did this
segment on a show where she catches on
hidden camera one of her guests stealing
and she handles it in a way that is
really quite cringy and hard to watch
but art is ethic look the show 14 years
ago I said this is going to be like a
relationship and the most important
thing the foundation of a good
relationship is say it with me separate
thermostat okay that trust right Trust
is very important so before the show I
put out some Ellen products with a sign
that said only one per person and I just
wanted to see how honest my audience was
you know because it turns out you're
very honest very very honest we've set
up have you guys to know and dance by
the way unbelievable let me tell you
that lady can dance but how do you not
sure was the real Ellen or the fake one
mm-hmm
you know no I saw the fake know that she
sucks she doesn't she can't [ __ ] do
[ __ ] like ellentube it sound like a porn
site yeah good like it's got a watermark
on this it says Alan - it sounds like
we're people like like Ellen parody porn
we're like people dress up like Ellen
and then have lesbian sex or something
or they like try having sex with the man
for the first time that she likes it but
she didn't realize why is this 70 town
we got the joke maybe and maybe in one
episode like yeah she's like look under
your seat and then there's like a sex
toy there and then turned it to a huge
orgy no she doesn't get the look under
you see that's Oprah well she does it
everyone does it look under see it's
that one - Beulah this is my family LT
was a dirty dirty place guys now I get
sued by Owen we're getting sued today
wherever mine CNN oh my god we're just
going to leave the country of that
like give up be an American like people
who collect and what do you call it
tickets like from there you know how
some people I wonder car like a million
tickets they just gave out right right
we're going to be like that lawsuit yeah
yeah yeah another lawsuit fine Marty and
debt like fifty million dollars just
another parking ticket
you should applaud yourself that's
really it's really tough to because you
know nobody's watching you don't think
so we set up hidden cameras just to make
sure so watch how honest this lady is
right here watching the videos do you
think it's fake I mean III wouldn't I
would not doubt it for a salute split
second I tell you why the way they're
it's almost like they were doing it for
the video
that's roll is gonna say is do they
probably wouldn't know like no one would
say that though if it was real bill just
say take another one for my girlfriend
but they're with their friends they're
having a great time I get the feeling
that it's fake year then you're probably
right I was going to say it's watching
these like run women like freaking out
over Ellen merch is something to behold
here's a hat this is al-anon it's not
that big of a deal you guys I wouldn't
even recommend wearing that in public
but what do I know
so she's warded it pretty sounds inside
so you put that back and you weren't
going to take it and you own it so I
have the Hat for you that's the way I
got the story was that you it's getting
there
boiler alert okay I guess I shouldn't
watch yo get back sorry
spoiler alert okay that's for you for
being honest you don't have to buy it
now look here's a $10 merch shot
congratulations
hit that that's so amazing I mean any
and you could have taken more than one
thing and you didn't except for these
ladies right here
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go
[Music]
oh there she is oh so this one it gets
really really rough okay
[Music]
[Music]
so so these girl I guess what happened
was Alan said as part of her social
experiment she's a YouTube prankster now
she says to our audience over you can
have one free item so embarrassing that
dude thank God so this okay does the
does the punishment fit the crime I
don't think you know yeah I don't think
so either so this one girl who's in the
audience now and she taped her under in
secrecy took like an extra pin I can't
imagine that pin cost more than five
dollars no and so now she's got her on
the camera showing her crime and
humiliate people watch Ellen like 5
million people yeah so you pretty much
ruined I mean kind of ruin at her like I
was so quick to say that it's got to be
fake because like what's the I don't
know maybe they need their permission
right well no no no they get their
permission because her own words well
before they they sign a release when
they go on the show cuz they're in the
audience too they sign a release before
they even enter the building they all
sign releases hmm definitely that's so
embarrassing so like yeah so let's let's
measure the crime and the punishment
here so she's here being absolutely
humiliated not just in the crowd but to
everyone watching that's five that's
million everyone who knows her is going
to see this
[Music]
then she goes back and she returns one
of her stolen items and in which is it
on fire well she didn't I'll go an
additional item yeah
it shows some character like she didn't
steal any more I mean I was like this
[ __ ] stole one of my hats and now I'm
gonna ruin her life can you imagine like
she's in your employee or you're dating
this girl and you're like this this I
mean I don't know that she did do that
I'm very conflicted on this but let's
continue this has got to be one of the
more I never and I uncomfortable things
I've ever seen on television like I
don't know where she gets off with this
moral high ground - it's like this woman
probably makes twenty five thousand
dollars a year yeah Alan's a billionaire
and she's she's sitting up there
educating people in the morals of not
stealing a $10 hat and you're like
listen in her mind I'm kind of okay with
her being like this is a billy this is
they make so much [ __ ] money I can
steal a hat and nobody cares I get paid
a thousand dollars a month [ __ ] it
oh yeah it's not that crazy it's not
like she stole a car I mean there's
different levels of theft I'm just
coming you know it's just that's not
cool
so what's so embarrassing it's on her
it's so over the top and Ellen sitting
up there like the judge and jury she's
like George Washington the white power
powdered wig it's like that you're a
billionaire what do you know about
poverty
hello hi what's your high sister
couldn't come so that was her souvenir
yeah
yes our rowdy people sisters couldn't
come so what is your name Nancy Nancy
saw I'm Nancy what do you think about it
a bit my disgust at it makes me dislike
Ellen yeah it's not cool
I don't know like it's just a hat all
this unmerge hat of March like all the
sudden you're in the show and then the
cameras on you and Ellen on television
when the most popular shows in America
also like interning you in case your
boss didn't realize you just saw you on
TV what's your name yeah what's your
name where you live can I get you Social
Security number do you mind if I send
this to everyone you know so uh look I
like that you like the product so much
that you wanted to bring one back for
your sister but um now when you go like
to Costco or or you're the kind of
person like when you go
trick-or-treating and nobody's home you
don't just take that you take the bowl
you just walk away no no listen I I
really she's actually the type of person
that would like cheat on your spouse
your this you're the type of person
you're the type of person that if keys
were in a car you just get up and take
it right the the stuffs were there for
free right so they were like supposed to
take one yeah it's so not the same as
stealing from Costco not even not even
close
also she took your merge hat that's free
promotion for you if your sister wears
it on the street it's like shut up
it's your merge she should have stolen
yeah of course
well that's just let's say that still is
wrong let's acknowledge that right away
but Ella and so grow your billionaire
ass off that [ __ ] high horse you give
you faced elf looking dancer
I don't get Alan I'm sorry I just don't
get Alan I understand the appeal I don't
think she's funny I don't think she's
charming I'm sorry I don't get Alan what
about Lucas yaqoub yuck I find him more
interesting than Alan but it's his dream
to be on this show well he's got to do a
start stealing [ __ ] I'm sorry that's
embarrassing and everything but you know
let that be a lesson to you cuz you
think you think nobody's watching you
and you just need to be a good person
just because you want to be a good
person you go sit in that Ellen jail
over there right now this is so [ __ ]
[Applause]
yo kids this is so fun stuff back there
come here this is still hard to watch
he's putting her and it's fair on the
stage I made like a grade for section to
it what's your sister's name I know that
when you when you feel better I'd like
shavers and your back yeah I just felt
about you got the Korean shivers we need
to get the masks in here the whole
hazmat suits Anna got you in big trouble
[Music]
so they they not okay I guess Alan maybe
thought it was just like a playful haha
funny thing but they loved this clip so
much they actually upload it on her
Channel
I thought I actually think it's
disgusting I'm horrified by this
it's got time nine point two million
views that's like that's a large
percentage of the whole of American
population now knows oh comments are
disabled Wow way to be brave Alan you
know what [ __ ] you Alan if you could
have pulled this [ __ ] you don't disable
the comments you take the heat for it
seriously I got beef with Ellen now this
shit's out not cool and by the way I
think that lady seems like not that good
of a person not even like her
I had a bad reception of her but that's
being said I don't like anyone involved
in this video
[ __ ] me that is so stupid we could all
be creamed Jack I know I just like it
everyone's spamming the cringe loco and
uh that is seriously so [ __ ] up I
don't get Alan look at her this is her
logo she's like hiding and crawling you
ever watched a long segment
I watched and I'm always in disbelief
like why why what is this why I don't
know Eli you're a woman tell me why do
people like Ellen what do you think that
all women either while I explain it to
me yes women love Ellen you just you
know she has like you just outraged all
of the women in the world I don't watch
out I don't know I watch Ricki Lake oh
yes
champs Oh that about this knees no this
needs went away that's almost that's
even worse than the sneeze itself so
it's been
oh it's 420 how about that you wanna do
a spot I wanna wait has it been an hour
and a half ready kind of what alright
let's take a moment let's think if I
could treat an hour and a half or did we
start late not that late yeah let's
let's um we got a we got to talk about
our sponsors so let's get into that
let's I'm actually hungry let's do
naturebox
so as we spoke about and the last time
one of the previous episodes naturebox
is a snack company who has online snacks
this is what they wrote so I want to
read I have comp I don't know if I
should read the copy or do my own thing
let me try reading the coffee three days
we all want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks sometimes it feels like
the whole world is delicious in a
billion calories first boring and
tasteless it doesn't have to be that way
up your snack game with nature hogs oh
is that is that effective nature walks
has over a hundred snacks that taste
good and are actually better for you all
snacks are made from high-quality simple
agrees which means no one are free to go
to Sweden so you can feel good about
what you're eating you get the idea
there dank ass healthy fresh snacks that
you get online now here's the best part
you they're healthy and they're great
you order them because they're bomb and
here's the great part if you go to
nature box.com /h 3 you get 3 free
snacks wow that's a great offer
pretty good you support the show thank
you for doing that and you get three
free snacks well last time we talked
about nature snack we didn't have the
stacks but we ordered them let's give em
a try
all right so where we get we got salt
and pepper little bloop oh my god
turning to a smorgasbord find everything
some pepper a little oops nice
oh yeah that's healthy but is oh damn
not bad where's my listen to me crunch
try that corn sticks
oh [ __ ] or the bomb oh whoa hello I like
it I like this one better janna fake one
sticks so now everyone at home loot look
under you sit look under your seat
actually you don't need to do that just
go to nature box.com / h3 and you can
get three free healthy and delicious
snacks sniper is coming the link in the
check snipes thank you Dad
these are actually good eyes want to eat
these guys eat this traumatic I just
want to tell everyone a little footnote
about snipers you do should I wait until
we finish this oh just how you consol it
so snipers is our friend Nile and he
started a little clothing line company
on his own called pearly whites and I'm
actually wearing this shirt from them I
love him snipers is one of my good old
YouTube friends we're constantly such a
long time I was had a fondness in my
heart for any such a great will dude
pearly whites yeah but nothing
oppressive white lastly to be talking
about naturebox
one of them paid it's all really good
actually so try this I did all my
druthers steel ride Shah cashews surly
coffee kettle corn dried out this is
really entertaining all right for me
this is that's probably show so this is
the one I was waiting for Syrah chopped
roasted cashews this is the one I had my
own hmm
delicious so good the coffee popcorn I
was going to that one I think this is my
favorite the corn one that I honestly
they're all going to do they're all
likely better than any snack you can
find the grocery store for my money
so all those it's my key you search your
bite pens are good Sam we just canceled
the show want to eat much Madison
naturebox calm
the show support our sponsor who we love
and appreciate have a really great
product those are delicious snacks thank
you to them
thank you you guys we got links in the
chat Lincoln bio leek and bio so a nuts
like a god Church oh this shirt that I'm
wearing is already sold that's crazy so
now yeah now sold out of all the [ __ ]
well you guys get the link on that
naturebox [ __ ] cool yeah next up we have
another sponsor you know you love them
me on DS we've previously spoke about me
on DS let me do a cut low copy right
here me on DS is the softest most
comfortable underwear you'll ever wear
period and the summer is the perfect
time to upgrade your underwear drawers
because your balls get super sweaty they
doing right and that's our fun just
can't can save that babka douche
that's why you need me undies it's
always say you're just going to read it
was that good was that not good
baba ganoush where was i baba ganoush
normal cotton
listen it's summer it's hot I don't know
where you live but in LA it's a hundred
degrees right now these normal underwear
it's like a swamp down there but when I
wear my undies it's like a nasty swamp
with like sulfur gas and [ __ ]
like creatures there's no I got a
beautiful new life sprit well I'm
getting to new life crawling out of my
underwear it's like a petri dish
disgusting but with my undies soft
breathable wonderful and great look and
feel and great they are the ultimate
feel-good undies every pair of neon DS
is sustainably sourced
made for Michael or micro middle of
fabric that's three times softer than
cotton I like that they actually have
like a measurement of that scientists
have crunched the numbers and it's three
times softer than conscious glad that we
have a measure really it is actually
insane Mikayla comfortable I love I love
we got several pairs from them and I
wear them whenever they're clean okay
well you know good I know some people
who are in dirty
I had a friend of college she would wear
the same underwear for like gross you
know who it is his name starts with the
K yeah he would he would wear the same
underwear and socks for a week I would
like to and he's like a big nasty hairy
sweaty guy and we're like dude that
isn't now and he's like no we're like
don't you ever like smell your underwear
I feel like one day and you've just had
your head back at in disgust and like I
smell it it smells fine I'm like Dawg
get your nose check with your disgusting
monster so that was just a bit of a side
but with me on days you can wear these
for a week says right here you can wear
them for a week and not create new
organisms in your crotch tip me on DS
does it say another don't say it I'm not
saying it does not say that I'm not
there copy but here is their copy you
got to see them for yourself
and right now here listen up 20% off
your first pair and receive free
shipping only at me on Descamps / h3 you
get 20% off and free shipping you got
nothing to lose you get this uncredible
the softest pair of underwear you've
ever felt in your life free shipping me
Andes comm /h the read America we get
nuts spammed in the comments yep let's
take a look at their website really fast
because just so I can show you because
we don't have a parent here to show you
guys me and these calm / h3 let me just
show you what kind of stuff they got
just to give you an idea gross
oh that's it gross colors cross colors
I'm like you know I'm not sure that's
the best marketing approach anyway
they've got all you know they got
everything
you guys know what underwear looks like
but this one is very soft and it's great
you get the idea and markiplier loves
them when we were talking about with
Mark he was freaking out how do I find
more options there's boxer briefs trunks
boxers briefs yeah oh they have crew
necks and stuff interesting yeah I bet
those are great okay enough about that
thank you for supporting okay we love
our sponsors and we love our fans if you
want to support the show consider
picking up some underwear or some snacks
god bless you all right crash so my
let's take five minutes run to the
bathroom yeah guys we have honestly so
much great stuff still to talk about if
you leave right now
I just have a really bad feeling I have
a really bad feeling
I'm not saying something's going to
happen I don't know what could possibly
happen but if you leave check under your
seat when you get back regula and then
yep okay
well I'm gonna run the bathroom there's
going to be really quick break we'll be
right back don't leave something
horrible is going to happen I know it
welcome back everybody to top of the
month h3 podcast we have a lot of
content left do not go anywhere because
we are just getting started
up next is D bill cosby hey hey hey
you know about that yeah so as as many
of you probably know Bill Cosby was
recently accused of raping like a
thousand ladies I mean this guy is like
a rape enthusiast apparently raping is
like breathing to Bill Cosby apparently
he takes a breath and also and he raped
someone all these times he was trying to
sell us all jello well we're in the
jello exactly what wasn't it because you
see now gel is made it's like powder and
water and you see how people do date
rape drugs it's like a little powder and
a drink it's soaked date rape is so
close to making jello it makes me wonder
what has been in the jello all these
years
anyway so let's watch the video so when
he gets out of court this is what
happens during a one of his court dates
[Music]
so beat in the muck get in the mind of
Bill Cosby if you can it's walking out
of court if you got something like that
he would do and in one of his shows or
something it's not it's from an old show
called Fat Albert okay
his slogan was hey hey hey so it's doing
a meme but a little bit of a bad timing
a little a little bit just a tiny bit so
get into the mind of Bill Cosby if you
can
he's coming out of court people are
asking him a day you know do you have
any comment you raped everybody
everybody spit rape and then his mind
the appropriate response to all this is
hey I don't know if he's lost it was it
funny maybe it's funny nothing is really
funny in that situation yeah there's not
much humor left there honestly
well Chappelle had a great what was
Chappelle's want was it Chappelle who
said he rapes but he saves yeah well in
his Netflix allyship I could throw that
up if you guys haven't seen Dave
Chappelle's Netflix special you gotta
check it out he has a great bit about
Bill Cosby he rapes but he saves does
the rape outweigh all the good he did
for community sorry to say he rapes but
he saves and he goes hey hey hey so he's
still trying to entertain the people
yeah
oh god its next the whole Bill Cosby
thing I'm fascinated by he let you stop
trying to stop trying to get me to go
you probably should because we have so
much talk well but I got to talk about
Bill Cosby that guy is fascinating
he like was such a huge advocate for
block rights and advancing the black
artists in the community itself that's
what they suppose yeah and but how do
you as a person live with that duality
of like I'm he's super high every time
he talked it was all from like the high
ground a moralistic high ground like I'm
Bill Cosby I'm doing all this great
thing for the world
how can you on one hand be that person
but at on the other hand just be raping
people like crazy it's complicated in
the world people always go people are
messy this is the common OS people are
messy and life's messy it's like yeah I
accept that but you're I mean you're
raped you raping people like you mix
jello
it's a tricky question does the good he
did outweigh great go ask someone we're
not well by psychology to tell you about
that is it possible to separate them to
be like the good the bad was good the
bad was bad we don't need to mix them
because he as a as a person he's a piece
of [ __ ] I don't know because this [ __ ]
is insane it's not trying to rape
someone you got to do it once it's
pretty rough something is like whatever
I don't know what's going on in his mind
I don't think I you know if I screw down
figure that out yeah because you know
like he raped one person it's like man
that that was good bad or good or
whatever but I like the 30th one he's
like I'm getting pretty good at this
rape thing I wonder if you like
streamlined it I don't like talking
about it it's too heavy you don't talk
about streamlined rape no I don't like a
McDonald's hamburger alright let's move
on he was getting uncomfortable about
Bill Cosby well if you're getting got a
problem to do that you have a serious
problem
obviously it's fascinating alright you
love you sorry accept my apology I'll
leave you with this
what's that haunt your dreams Gila
moving on to you I have only this to say
ela hey let's move on this one I hate to
watch it but I have to because I'm
friends with jesse wellens I love the
guy I actually really like him he's a
really cool great guy
but he recently jesse wellens from
prankvsprank on youtube you guys know
who he is he was hosting an event at e3
this year and this has got to be one of
the most brutal cringe things I've seen
in a long long time but it's so
fascinating and great to watch me open
this up when I'm done
good ok so I'll give a little back story
I'm gonna hate you for watching why is
he gonna hate me he made a video about
on his channel I have to acknowledge it
yeah
wait this one's missing the beginning
let me see if there's a better version
ok yeah this one's better so I'm sorry
getting this turn like look at this
tournament it cracks me the [ __ ] up so
what he said in his video is like him he
thought he wasn't on for another ten
minutes so they're like Jesse you're on
and so he wasn't efficient whatever he
was even ready yeah I thought the term
when I first watched he's trying to be
cool but he's just a deer in headlights
whatup guys thank you for having me ei
if you guys don't know who I am
I wonder if he was almost like what up
pants well that's his slogan is the what
up peeps yeah and when me and and we're
making a parody of YouTube vloggers we
said what up pimps my name is jesse
wellens and now I can't stop saying it I
am a YouTube creator so I am here to
talk about need for speed
wait this is anything a little bit
payback if you guys didn't know
Nicci payback oh god don't do that I
didn't just play the clip I'm bung yeah
it's great good but I also decide I mean
YouTube creator defeat hey this is so
brutal yeah I'm you feel traitor
I'll set aside coming out and then what
is he he says his name and then
introduces him from a different name
it's really funny I got my blue mark his
executive party out here he is the
producer of the game Thank You Nick my
boy mark is good Thank You Nick that's
my favorite
and then he'd like shutters on it so
it's like Thank You Nick I love Jesse
what happen though I didn't want to is
we can walk nation about it well I can I
can I can defend them pretty well I
think the reason why this is so
fascinating to me is because I see
myself there I know I may do like I can
see this happening to me oh yeah it's
way it's way too close to home like we
recently did the livestream care star
breeze in the I didn't for the
announcing the payday 2 DLC which I'm
very excited about by the way we've been
doing voiceover for that it's been
really fun
he'll has been mm-hmm just to go on a
little tangent we've been doing
voiceover for the DLC payday 2 they're
adding me Neil as playable characters it
should be coming out in a couple months
and ela has been hailing it on the
voiceover it was really hard for me
first and then they brought someone like
a voice acting coach their cylinder held
me they're so nice and it was actually
really helpful really either was like
listen I can't because we went and did
it once for trial and in all fairness
like you couldn't get loud and you you
were had trouble like I had no when we
got into this whole thing I had no idea
what it was actually going to be like
actually we have to do like 300 pages of
lines like we have to do like 20 hours
of studio recording of voiceover and you
need to yell and like being in character
so so at first they're like ela was like
listen she was feeling really bad she's
like I don't think I can do this and she
wrote our contact there and she's like
if you want to cut me and just do ela or
just do Ethan I totally understand and
they're such gracious great people
they're like they're like [ __ ] no we're
including you ela kleiner for life and
they got her a voice coach yeah an
acting coach and they've been doing
sessions together and we went in
yesterday for voiceover and he'll it was
like crushing it all like holy [ __ ] I
was so impressed it's pretty cool though
I'm just I'm really excited for that to
come out it's gonna be a ton of fun I
can't wait for that anyway back to this
story
so anyway I was saying we did a stream
for them we flew out to Sweden and did
this whole big live stream we're mean
Eva were guests on there and I was so
nervous that OH
cause what happened
why does idubbbz get away with it but I
can't he's not sitting here I don't know
what's up where's Oh guys hey sorry
sorry I should have apologized sooner
but I thought that I was going to this
was going to be me on that live stream
and there's something horrible horrible
I've liked here we're in our studio it's
in our environment yeah you know but
there it's like in their environment and
you're talking about [ __ ] at least I
didn't have a script
the script if I I can't do scripts I
think my dyslexia like any time like we
did that video with Vsauce yeah oh my
god you guys I'm so [ __ ] dumb like we
did this video with Vsauce and I had
like three lines first script and it
took me like an hour it was so brutal to
get it right I got it right at once and
I don't think it was very good they're
like ok coke a good wrap it wrap it wrap
it oh my god I can't do lines so anyway
my heart goes up to Jesse yeah I so bad
but he was saying essentially like he
was super nervous about doing it from
the beginning the teleprompter was all
messed up
it was unsynched and it was different
from what he had rehearsed and then the
best part is like the beginning just
kills me like look at this can you
imagine like Jesse Jesse you're on and
he's like what what up what up guys
thank you for having me EA if you guys
don't know who I am my name is jesse
wellens and I am a YouTube like and he's
like playing it so hard like I hope that
it goes sleeper so I am here too
alright we'd have to watch this again or
do we know anyway my heart goes out to
you Jesse hey guy what a haps
we're actually hopefully gonna do a
collaboration with them soon we want to
do a lookbook we're like all these looks
that I've done all these goofy ht3 memes
because Jesse actually does like serious
lookbook videos that are super well shot
editing super talented filmmaker so we
thought it'd be funny to have that
professional style filming and editing
but with my looks
instead of like an actual song yeah
hopefully we can do that soon he'll be
great what do you want to watch sting
embarrassed by cover dude gets caught
breaking in that was amazing
this is a good one you wanna watch out
let's watch all them [ __ ] it we
agreement so man this one's pretty
brutal
so Pierce Morgan is on I don't know
really the back story here but he hosts
the show with Susan
Susanna Reid and I I guess this guy's
must be pretty annoying because it seems
like everybody has had it up to here
with him and well this is just a great
moment we agree when people start
banging on about politics on Facebook I
really annoys me I've had to unfriend
the family members because this is how I
can't but please I need some respite
can't you just put a picture of your
little kid so having an ice-cream
yeah when someone just keeps going on
and on and on and you just need rest
sigh and a break and you just wish you
can see from them and but you just
forced every day to listen to their
views I know exactly how you feel
she's talking about him and he's just
like what's aw [ __ ] Tobin it's awesome
look at for the best part there because
it seems like a meme right and I love
the camera work they keep getting those
like a Mickey thing closes of a spade
response can't you just put a [ __ ] and
when she finished they just moved right
pasty he didn't even say anything about
it so I think he was clearly very butter
during your little kid having an ice
cream I don't know the hands they have
banter a lot so who the [ __ ] knows yeah
I'm trust anything I see on television
unless it's on shark tank I buy
everything there I love sharks hey can I
talk about that as a my new obsession
the best show shark tank you expect it
to be really stupid mm-hmm but it's
amazing it's so good and I love that
there's no like fake drama
they don't try to make you cry every
time sometimes every time like some you
know someone has a sad story
they let him say it and then everyone's
like I'm out yeah but it's real it's
actually like the real reality show
where they have these investors and they
actually have their money on the line
that they do look back on people and see
how the deals are doing it's fascinating
it's like educational it's dramatic it's
oh I love that show
I didn't expect to check out Shark Tank
everyone is probably already like we're
late to the game we just started
watching it for somebody I feel like I'm
like talking I just discovered this new
show shark tank have you guys heard of
it every time I cooked something lucky
I've been watching appears yeah
I don't watch TV I don't know what's
going on there have you guys heard about
the show Seinfeld I just discovered it
have you heard of Seinfeld surprisingly
funny show all right next up this was
great so apparently stink you guys know
the the rock musician he's being honored
in this ceremony and they have this
performer playing the song fact his
famous song back to him every step you
take and it's really an awful version
I'm surprised that that that this is who
they got for this and you can see sting
as [ __ ] hates it you can't even hide
his disgust it's pretty surprising
[Music]
what's that finding with a good time
[Music]
it sounds pretty bad some very amateur
every breath you take every move you
make every bond you break every oh I'll
be watching you I mean it's like pretty
amateur it's not that bad honestly it's
a little goofing to begin every shuttle
ding reaction what kills it does every
word you say but every game you play
every night you stay I'll be watching oh
my god you can't even hide his
suggestion like you think and they're
zooming in on it they're making it so
much awkward anybody what you think it's
his awards ceremony so you think that he
would be on at least like smile and play
along so imagine how much this cover is
actually discussing him he looks like
he's actually in pain he probably is
[Music]
but everywhere
everywhere you see value-free
I got that now just listen the thing is
in having them you take I'll be watching
you
[Music]
get all of this my my you have to tear
you doing
[Music]
I love this slow zooming pan they have
on his leg
all right laughter that should resting
wrist people are saying oh is that cart
guitar player blind I don't think so
he's just one of those cool last folks
with classes dude gets caught breaking
and this is a classic this one is not
from this month but I haven't talked
about it yet so let's go have you seen
this Gila you're gonna love this
no it's called - dude gets caught trying
to break into his neighbor's house who
was watching the whole time
you imagine people are saying that is
blind and we just made fun of him
I didn't make fun of him for being blind
what just good someone's blind you can't
talk [ __ ] on them also I'd even pile it
on him read oh my god he's blind you
can't seem to even talk about him God
forbid anybody has some kind of
disability well I have no idea I don't
know leave me alone leave me out of this
I don't care if he's blind dude
so you sucks at playing guitar you can
be blind and good and playing music I'm
not saying that if you're blind you
can't play music good you could still
suck at [ __ ] is that a revelation a war
is I'm not bad all right
let's watch it [ __ ] that blind guy why
did he see
why don't you see idiot work on your
vision dum-dum before you pick up a
guitar I hate blind people right EULA I
was trying to watch this by the way
I wasn't doing anything the problem
throughout was doing anything I promise
look at this [ __ ] guy's faded this is
the kind of guy he looks like he was
breaking into like sniff his underwear
or something he's not you didn't wanna
steal anything you just want to give us
undo this no thumbs I wasn't you know I
wasn't you I wasn't I wasn't question I
was trying to cook into you like this
more the most pathetic video this
spotted guy man get Michael if I don't
stop trying to [ __ ] have much more to
do it on I swear to god dude dude I was
not bring in your house dude we think he
was breaking in to steal [ __ ] or to
smells underwear finally smell I know
that's what I think too
cuz it's his neighbor like you can't
steal [ __ ] and go next door that is so
weird
do you think he was there smell his
underwear jizz under his pillow I don't
know but I think it was up to something
weird definitely up to something weird
he wasn't after monetary gain he was
after weird sexual gratification that's
my hunch I was in dude he says just
excuses if they confused was that his
lock was [ __ ] up so he was
troubleshooting to learn how to fix his
lock on his door really that's what he
said yeah nothing crazier helps to hear
me did you hear me do my doorstop number
I was trying to [ __ ] get another door
follow me how to do it and I'm sorting
out with a song at Ranger house my mom
talked to my decision it's like laying
on the ground I mean this is a special
kind of video yeah a special kind of
Ville you don't come around often we
need to cherish these moments footage
from the people to him on the ground
please just get up and leave Doug Doug
do you hear me remember I told you their
name break my Scrolls about that us
about that for video where is Ellen now
can we get yet there is contood alright
house one any call material you have
anything add no the special kind of
video does not come around every day
mexic okay this is a great one mexican
smash face and cake meme is what I wrote
I have a great story that goes along
with this so apparently Mexicans have a
tradition that when it's your birthday
you smash the person's head into the
cake as they're singing really yeah
that's what my dad told me he they lived
in Mexico for five years and I have a
story that corroborates this so they
have this tradition that they smash your
head into the cake are these people
Mexican am I an [ __ ] because that
were weapons wearing a headscarf oh my
god they're not Mexican oh [ __ ] loser
what the [ __ ] oh my god alright I
apologize you just wanted to tell you a
story I'll tell the story spill but ok
[ __ ] me I apologize Mexicans are not
represent every race in the world all
people of color are not the same Christ
that was embarrassing
what I thought I had to Garbo's like I'm
a white guy I just became a white guy
officially alright whatever
ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
friends like visa let me let me shove my
friend my god the cameos yeah I just
thought about it
Wow like that's like a lot of fire
imagine if you didn't he would what the
[ __ ]
what friends like these who needs
enemies having a laugh Allah so anyway
here's my story okay
my story about Mexican still stands all
right let's just pretend these were
Mexicans for the sake of the story does
that work can I do that mmm okay these
weren't let me have a sip silly so when
I was like five I was at a Mexican
restaurant and we went there for my
dad's birthday and my dad being the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that he is yeah can
you imagine doing this to your poor son
we go to this Mexican restaurant and
it's his birthday and when we get there
he says it's my son Ethan's birthday hmm
so when we finish eating all they all
come out and they bring me a piece of
cake and they're singing to me I'm a
young kid I'm confused I'm like it's not
my birthday so he was just pranking you
he was pranking me but here's when it
gets weird we're uh when they're done
when they're done singing they had me
blow out on the candle it's just one
candle not like a scorching inferno like
we saw here and they shove my face full
power into the cake they who the
server's the waiters no way I swear to
God and then I wasn't prepared at all
who the [ __ ] prepared for that it gets
in my nose in my mouth I'm choking and I
puke at the table and I'm crying I'm
bawling my eyes are not puking my mom
runs me into the bathroom I'm a young
child I my my dad fought to be fair he
didn't know that happened the waiters
just did that to you they shoved
into the [ __ ] cake and I like inhaled
and then I puked on the table as one of
my most transformative childhood
memories
like okay do you always pick on the cake
yeah all over myself oh my god
like clearly he didn't know that they
would like what I have restaurant it was
a really big popular restaurant in our
town center oh wow
it's at a business now make sense they
shoved one too many faces in case but I
don't know I still give my dad shifts
that more like they give me [ __ ] for
that people are still getting [ __ ] for
that to this day that has nothing to do
with the people in this video in any way
at all okay let's move on next we need
more icon to anymore - which icon we
need like a and sound for like now oh
you're so true Dan I want to get a
soundboard where we get like slamming
Bradbury's and necks so like you can you
can be like the audio engineer are you
up for that
cool oh yeah I want to get weird and
wild with the show we can step this up
to weirder parts Ethan hates blind guys
thanks guys plus one the name of this
episode I just saw someone post that in
the comments all right let's move it on
dude goats caught breaking in Mexicans
scratch out Mexicans people smashing
face and cake me too late
so this Instagram model that we've been
talking about recently wasn't in
Christian burns yep a keemstar
god bless his soul posted a video of him
trying to stab someone I'm getting a
little concerned about this guy I'm
thinking that we probably shouldn't make
fun so he clearly is very unstable
person mm-hmm which makes me content
yeah we shouldn't watch this video
regardless we're gonna watch the video
but keep in mind that he probably needs
help
this isn't like funny at this point but
he's in this house with all these [ __ ]
boys mm-hmm the people in this house are
incredible I haven't sinned as are you
serious you know
so let me just play it anyway the
stories he's trying to stab someone in
this house that they're all sharing
[Music]
telling you it's like the real world
with no cameras drop the knife who are
all these people
Wow what happened like beyond creation
trying to stab someone like how did we
get all these people in the one house
this is Los Angeles in basically one
short video okay christ almighty that's
crazy so the dude is a little unstable
yeah he's out there he's trying to stab
people
it's not cool give him a break I think
give him a break he's a meme with a
knife
name is one thing but a meme with a
knife it's a whole different ball game
should I keep watching it nah thank you
Andy I get the idea again who's [ __ ] no
so go easy on the poor
why did can't start wit it it came
started he's a garden gnome what
connections all over the place
this one's fascinating polygon article
about Anita sarkeesian you guys all know
Anita sarkeesian
I actually didn't know her before
historian really so she's one of the
most prompt this New Age very prominent
feminist and I've seen some of her
videos called feminist frequency where
she talks about how video games are
misogynistic and I am NOT extremely
familiar with her work and all fairness
to her I can't
I don't feel well informed enough to
make a full assessment of who she is and
what she does but I asked you in one of
her videos where she's looking at like
hitman two
and she's like showing a clip of the
main protagonist walking through a strip
joint and like she's like this is
obvious that there's sex toys and that
the
character can do whatever he wants with
her and she shows footage of the
character like assassinating strippers
and doing all these horrible things and
she's like this character this game is
super misogynistic
and promotes really dangerous rapey
behavior and then when you actually play
the game you find out that you lose
money you you get penalized by hurting
the strippers in any way okay it's a
stealth mission you're not supposed to
kill the strippers that's not the
objective of the game that's what she
made it sound like
so she really she's not very honest in
this interview and so recently what
happened was this guy sargon of akkad
again not super familiar with his work
so I can't make a judgment call about
his character but he was sitting in at a
panel at VidCon about what was it
feminine or women on on the internet or
something she was having a panel write
about women on internet and I will say
this I'm not talking to the panel itself
I don't I don't know what they were
talking about I think that women do have
a heart on the internet so I'm not gonna
like attack that but I mean like but
this guy's are gonna cut who she's had
beef with in the past was sitting in the
front row and she says some [ __ ] like
she says he's sitting there and I mean
he was just sitting there he didn't say
anything right he didn't say nothing I
can see it obviously like there's
obviously been beef between guns and any
sitting there it's probe on her panel
yeah it's definitely provocative but he
didn't say anything and so she calls him
human garbage with unprovoked she said
some really horrible things where was it
I can see let me find what she said to
make actually Anita sarkeesian um what
was his name
Sargon Sargon of Akkad oh yeah and
apparently there was something with
boogie 2 with her oh yeah man you know
there's a video of it for some reason I
can't find it
she honestly seems like a really rude
person based on my I'm really kind of
rude Mead person but to the best of my
recollection she says something like
cumin garbage like I'd like to talk
about this but there's human garbage
sitting on the front page on the front
row not willing to engage him and just
being super rude and not having a
fruitful debate just being extremely
rude and she was also super rude to
buggy who apparently did uh was on stage
with her and he said something that she
didn't agree with and afterwards she was
like that was super inappropriate and
got like triggered by something
completely the sweetest most
non-confrontational person in the world
so anyway polygon writes this article
about the situation that I found was
really saying I need to sarkeesian is
astounding garbage human moment feminist
speaker hits back at trolls and haters
so this is polygon which was kind of
interesting to see how the media covers
these kind of things because it seemed
like a they shared the blame I would say
they shared the blame in the situation
he was provocative she ultimately did
not take the high road she was committed
I think like if someone does that you
got a just shot and you know you got to
shut up and take it and still have your
panel yeah I would be like hey welcome I
hope you can have a civil debate yeah
I'm glad you're here let's let's talk
about this right so he was prerogative
but she took it to a really unproductive
and rude level so here's how here's how
polygons covered this a faux camera is
trained on Anita sarkeesian as she
prepares to speak on a panel and footage
later posted online the camera wall was
slightly ok I don't need the [ __ ]
colorful language
some what happens after so many public
appearances circadian has grown
accustomed to speaking in front of a few
hundred people but but but today she
feels a certain intimidation crowd of
her most ferocious critics including
youtubers sit together in the front row
their forms their phones pointed at her
the camera carefully follows her as she
acknowledged is her co-panelists and she
checks her surroundings then she looks
directly into the camera she looks at
the man holding the camera sitting in
front of a row
carl benjamin is a british youtube
personality let's get on with it
he's made me I'm just gonna read the
[ __ ] Carl Benjamin that's sarkeesian I
assume as a British YouTube personality
and was late 30s he has spoken
Sargon yeah he said Sergei
oh [ __ ] that's rough he spoken about
sarkeesian and her work some of it some
of his videos are thumbnails with
ludicrously photoshopped images of
sarkeesian at the time of writing his
twitter page is bannered with pictures
of sarkeesian bedroom has made his name
dismissing her feminist documentary work
such as tropes vs. women in video games
that's when I was talking about where
she was super dishonest with her
analysis which details the cultural bias
and video games he is a hero for many of
the hate group such as gamergate a rough
assemblage of misogynist racist
conspiracy theorists and white wit ring
ideologues who have spent years
harassing sarkeesian and anyone who
publicly supports her work that's so
ridiculous like you can't be a critic of
gamergate
or you're a right-wing harasser yeah
that's the new thing though that's the
reality now you're criticize anything
about your all your all pride it's your
with us or against us I don't I think he
is right he's like I don't know I can't
speak for him he might be but he might
be all right
but his criticisms of her from what I've
seen seem to be somewhat defensible
valid points anyway I don't know haven't
seen her stuff anyway but this is
definitely what's going on here where
this really progressive like radical
left their super anti free speech and it
comes to the point where you can't even
like this is what we saw with humongous
if you they are incapable of having a
conversation if you're against them
you're the [ __ ] enemy and you're a
racist misogynist it's so unproductive
it's great man so most of his YouTube
videos follow standard reactionary
protocols the his mouth froth the
content reserved for feminists a hot
topic for men who feel afraid and
threatened by progresses
nice editorial dum-dum do you hear that
no he says his most frothy content is
reserved for feminism a hot topic for
men who feel afraid and threatened by
progressiveness who they dismiss as the
regressive left well that's really such
a broad brush yeah I'm not familiar with
this content but I feel like they say
the same thing about me yeah it's true
whenever we're criticized social justice
warriors or say social justice warriors
than people think that we're all pride
just articles too long that I knew I do
serious yeah I don't my problem is that
I don't know either of them this is way
longer than I thought holy crap anyway
that my my my reaction essentially that
but I did see the clip or she called you
super river bridge and it seems so done
like if you wanted to be taken seriously
then still have your panel and let him
sit there and let him be the you know
the dumb dumb who came to annoy exactly
here well okay this is a big long
article but here let me at least read
how this ends when confronted with the
consequence of appalling behavior those
organizations that hosts abusive
activities including VidCon YouTube
twitch and twitter offer little more
than pleasantries and useless palliative
they are ignoring their own urgent duty
to show some courage to fully confront
these awful displace of bullying if
individuals like Anita sarkeesian can
stand up to such aggression why can't
these huge and powerful organizations
get [ __ ] real
alright that's all at the same [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
oh no I don't know I don't know what not
you're right I don't know enough about
it but that approach that like it's up
to Twitter YouTube and VidCon to protect
to shelter I saw what she said on that
stage it was very rude all right let's
move on to [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this is a great one this is an oldie and
a Goldie so these guys is a mega church
pastor and he got into some hot water
because he used church funds to buy
himself a private jet to most people
that may seem excessive but he had a
very good excuse for why he spent Church
money on - on a twenty million dollar
private jet and this isn't one of my
favorite videos so feast your eyes well
first before I read the script Amos
chapter 6 brother Copeland I was flying
home from a meeting and I had come out
of a glorious meeting I just found me in
Creflo Dollar would preach II had a
glorious meeting so I was for lack of a
better way to say it I was spiritually
hot people were saying touched and
blessed God in the plane that God so
graciously gave us we flying home as I
was going home the Lord real quickly
suggesting do you like your plane you
know I thought that's a hard statement
he gave us I agree it's odd
at what point like these people are
insane I mean they're criminals he's
talking to God about a jet like if your
God is so [ __ ] thing that he cares
about airplanes that is a weak-ass God
listen to this ship well certain memory
said do you really like it
he's like playing game well you like it
yeah I like it do you really like it I'm
God the all-powerful and I'm going to
spend my time talking to you about your
jet is not comedy well it is cup sorts
and I thought well yes Lord
he said then he said this so that's it I
didn't know how to handle it but man
what what he said is likely where I kept
my I wanna and you gonna let you fade
stagnate and when he said that that
shocked me I'm like whoa wait
I literally unbuckle my seatbelt my
plane I stood up my pilot's look what I
said do you need something that's no no
I'm talking to God right now they picked
me went back to fly I said a lot I don't
think I was letting my
stagnate he said so this is all I could
ever do I said you want that you you
trying to tell me something he said go
to the Book of Amos so if you had the
Book of Amos I want to read the script
yes or second this is great
this is amazing some beautiful mind [ __ ]
out of God he's like listen you guys are
all angry that I spent twenty million
dollars of church money on a private jet
take it up with God I know there's no
way to verify this but trust me God told
me he told me so
God said by private jet in her listeners
he gets it gets better you could have
done that on an airliner no sir no way
stand out and say what you say law no
okay no yes and the guy said no listen
what the hell he think he's doing dinky
doo can't do that hell no you can't do
that I love that also to talk to God
apparently you need to stand up and do
this oh and I go they're both like
helping each other here oh yeah they're
both in on the comm deep in the con
okay so God like he's like you can't
ride coach and talk to God you can't sit
there like this you need to do this get
real look at these [ __ ] lunatics
these guys are mixing some jello if you
ask me you know what I'm saying
alright bring another lawsuit I'm just
saying a joke what what did I I didn't
say anything this is so important and
those are visitors that are just now
coming into these things in in the first
plant you think that guy dies is here
yes his face looks like a [ __ ]
football Christ
man this is the low of the low two old
[ __ ] peddling religion to get rich
justifying buying a private jet like my
god
do they even believe what they're saying
he's wearing like a Gucci shirt so yeah
I don't know I don't think so yeah I
think at this level they're just full-on
self-aware con artists like there was
this know about people who do stop
believing they're on they drink their
own kool-aid so one of the most classic
examples that to me was so eye-opening
Randi the great long time ago there was
a huge mega church pastor and he used to
do these feats of miracles where he
would take out someone from the crowd
and he would magically know their name
know what was wrong with them he would
be like God is telling me there's a
Jessica in the crowd and you have
arthritis right and it was like
spectacular people were coming into like
this is amazing this oh the thing is
flashing the camera mm is that a battery
issue yeah hold on one sec we got to
change the battery on one of these
cameras all right just hang back chill
back we changed the bat you're on the
white shot Dan okay cool well that was
good that's good that indicates yeah
chill back Pat's face almost ready for
you that's a message from God telling
you to stop
nope that's just the camera so anyway
back back to the story so they're like
this is a miracle this is miraculous
this guy's doing this mega mega churches
there's thousands of people there and
somehow he knows the name and he knows
the [ __ ] the illness that people have
it's amazing and he is taking tons of
money he's selling God to all these
people thousands of people in the crowd
tens of thousands hundreds of thousand
people watching on television mm-hmm
donating millions of dollars so Randy
Newman is like this is fishy Randy
Newman dusted him Randy the great right
not Randy Newman I think that's the
musician and you the great Randy
Newman's also great but the wrong Randy
Randy the great the musician my mug
magician
so he's like this this is fishy so he
goes to the mega church he Scotto with a
professional with like a radio scanning
device and sure enough he hears in the
radio waves his wife in a earpiece
saying mrs. baba ganoush 32 years old
has arthritis in her left arm they had a
hole now I remember I spend into the
documentary yeah yeah so was when they
come in they look at their idea or
something right yeah they do like
pre-screening
so they take the information when the
people come in they says tell me a
little bit about yourself and they find
a good one they feed the information to
his wife who sits in a van outside and
talks to him in an earpiece it's crazy
so when you come to the question of like
are do these people believe this at all
or they just straight con men and that
case one of the biggest examples of one
of these megachurch guys was taking
millions of dollars from vulnerable
people was straight-up a comment here's
the craziest part they also believe they
also they start to believe that they
help people because they're like yes
sure
if it helps them then what does it
matter if it's real or not that's what
you like that's what these like cold
readers are like yeah but I'm still
doing something good that's [ __ ] the
aircon here's the craziest part I don't
believe that that pasture ever went to
prison and now like 15 20 years later
he's back on television and people are
still [ __ ] believing in him can you
believe that that's great
so the question being are these guys
caught I mean yes I think they are con
men I think like who the [ __ ] can be a
man of God and drop 20 million dollars
in a private jet 20 million do you know
how much good 20 million dollars can do
no never had joined Randolph yeah
good could do me a lot of good anyway Oh
Jesse and and and and I and and others
teeth more and creflo and all of us they
the world is in such a shape we can't
get there without this ice we got to
have this we would have the mesh that
the airlines are in today I would have
to stop I'm being very conservative at
least 75 to 80 more like 90% of what
we're doing because you can't get them
here it's impossible so we we had and
this was such a good illustration I just
the villain impressed me that's why
we're on that airplane we can talk too
hard Oregon we surely it's when I was
flying for Oral Roberts the brother do
Eastmont my boss on the airplane he
should not count official sanction to
that fruit just that financing that that
fake fruit on the table and so that's in
a [ __ ] symbol right there just like
shamelessly obviously just trying to
call up with excuses or whatever it's
funny this is the bottom barrel of
humanity there's fake fruit on the table
these are like fake the freaks the fake
fruit humans spent a long time I'm
having trouble talking but this to me is
as bad as humanity gets [ __ ] these guys
dude
Christ yep it protects the anointing on
the brother Roberts and he said you keep
your mouth shut don't talk to him unless
he talks because when he's on a meeting
he doesn't talk to anybody but God
now all used to flyer lines right but it
even back there in me it got to the
place where it was educating his
spiritual for coming up to him he had
become famous and they won't mean to
pray for him and all that you can't you
can't manage that today right this dope
filled world I get in and they're
getting along too with a bunch of demons
like oh my god demons just calling your
own your own contributors demons a long
tube with a bunch of demons
it's like he's describing his penis does
it kind of a good name right these guys
are [ __ ] losers how do you live with
yourself at night it reminds me of this
Bill Hicks joke where he's like these
people who work for like baby food
companies and put like poison into save
five cents they don't they have no
conscience he's like what'd you do too
hot what did you do today honey I put
some arsenic and baby food save save
five sets and go to sleep like a baby
you guys sleep like these guys sleeps so
good at night I bet you I don't know
about that on their golden pillows oh I
bet you these guys sleep great and I bet
you they mix yellow till they mix a lot
of jell-o and doughnut I do not know
about happy he was my attorney what
maybe yellow why all people love jello
is easy to eat it's soft on the teeth
what's wrong with jello deadly and and
he works on your heart it really does so
anyway I wanted to make that clear so
the devil can't lie to you and say see
that and breakers been and all that
money there's been the devil devil only
the devil would criticize me for wasting
twenty million dollars a [ __ ] jet so
I can't sit in a log tube that bunch of
demons get real you football faced Gucci
when jello mixing piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you'd you old ass [ __ ] your dyed
hair how fake can you be what's wrong
having gray hair you dyed your hair
black you fake [ __ ] you're faker than
the fruit on your table I have nothing
but honestly just hit hey mags
I still ain't clicking on that next [ __ ]
this guy there fat cats right now no
we're not we have business dude listen I
could scratch my flying itch with my
little single-engine open-cockpit
airplane
I just come home fly around in that
scratch my flying it that doesn't have
nothing to do with that but when we're
in weird sole business here right we got
a dying world around us Jess we got a
dying nation room that's right talking
and we can't even get their owner than
you can't let me give you an example for
I read the scripture if something said
why do you need an airplane it start out
about a couple of weeks ago I was in
full fourth I preached on a Sunday a
Friday night into Saturday I was in full
with preaching by Jerry Savelle Sunday
morning I was in Bop
Jimmy Jimmy oh don't tell me he just
said Jimmy Savile it can't be but not
some people said why do you need it
every Hill creeps me out how white his
shirt is that's not that white it's
white man because it start out about a
couple of weeks ago I was in full fourth
I preached on a Sunday a Friday night
and Saturday I was in full with
preaching by Jerry Savelle Jerry Savelle
Oh Jerry jimmy savile is a very
prominent serial pedophile from here
that would be the cream on top Sunday
morning I was in Boston Massachusetts
Monday I was in New Orleans
Tuesday I was in Chicago Wednesday I was
in Raleigh North Carolina Thursday was
in New Orleans Friday was in San Antonio
Texas Saturday I was in New Orleans
Sunday I was in enough making it up I
actually have a delta captain that lives
close to my house I brought in my
schedule I said can you fly this he said
no and I wouldn't if when do you sleep
we're about the fall here playing
airplane oil and grab it see ya now when
God is speaking this to me he said so
this is all I could ever do in a way if
they were like honest but that's just
what I was thinking just say that you
have a crazy schedule you're going to be
yes somewhere else everyday that's
better that would have been actually
kind of fun but God told me do you like
your hair plain I was on the airplane
colic deal like this airplane that link
diminishes their God in a way they're
like why would you cheapen your God like
that mm-hmm
God doesn't talked about airplanes dude
I'm thinking all right enough of these
[ __ ] limits okay MRSA these jello
mixing [ __ ] next I'll man there's so
much left dj khaled gets booed offstage
actually I'm gonna wash through this
video but i IE r dit Oh got removed she
there's a mirror in the comments when
she so apparently dj khaled did a set I
don't know where was it in Coachella and
oh my god I got removed I'm have to find
oh he did a set ash oh so he did a set
at EDC which is an electric music mm-hmm
festival and he's just doing it dj
khaled thing and everyone sterling
oh yeah
Wow nothing can stop me oh my god sorry
dude allergies are kicking my ass dude
oh that's go everyone like together
brooding well what happened oh my god
where's the tissue I gave you bald me
too
Oh die turn somewhere else I want to
give them a look
no thank you you got a duck out of the
way you're supposed to cover yourself
when you sneeze you do know that oh my
god
my whole face is so itchy I get this
itch in my throat it makes me go of the
wild ride
[Music]
well they did what happened I feel bad
for him I think people just didn't want
to hear dj khaled at EDC they're there
for for electronic music so but who
booked him wisely there that's the
question that's the Rope also I think
what part of the problem was like he
would play a song and then everyone will
get into it and then he switches the
song like every 30 seconds that's what I
think that's what they're keeping the
counter in the bottom left because he
switched the song every 30 seconds and
you don't get a chance to enjoy the
music oh you know we're done so now he's
over 50 30 songs 30 seconds he's not the
performer he's just out there screaming
and playing a song it's not a great set
this whole thing seems like such a fail
oh yeah
I mean my god Tara why Sidra this is
another good set sang it there's
honestly nothing worse when I see a
musician's musician on stage with a sing
it and it's just cricket somehow I feel
like they don't know because they always
go on with the smiles and stuff they've
got a note right that the crowd is cold
yeah I don't know okay I don't know I
guess they just like they have their dis
routine that they're used to do is they
do the same but when you're in a
festival not everyone is your fans
definitely see how bad you get the 11
songs in four minutes all right at this
point
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right yeah I totally understand why
was it good that's a disaster right
there my friends
ouch what is this Israeli prank invasion
hmm oh god voice is unbelievable
I think ela found this where'd you find
this so I'm going to recommend it it to
us somewhere I don't remember where good
guy this is stuff prank invasion has
made it to Israel he's in effect he's
like a virus he's infected every corner
of this earth but I miss him this is so
tough to see that in Israel like that
means it's probably like all over the
world
oh yeah if it made it to Israel tomato
everywhere so this is the Israeli prank
invasion if you laugh we kiss either
you're gonna have to do commentary going
up to translate how much of a machinima
what's that voice in your own voice mmm
it didn't hey baby if you laugh weekend
uh what a Pam did today that can be
ocular on in your smoke a stogie a sham
come on really
please subscribe my family Macedo well
yeah some things don't change wherever
you are
creek one wanted to get married on
what's he going on about why is there
blur on a show yeah oh they did it too
early it's early so you can't make them
laugh is gonna kiss them is he going to
take a letter some [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] lose my mind if you take alert
hey
- MA - ma diss me an EVO tell a tiara
mr. Kinnett remark any res no macho muda
name is Mikayla chica Denis simioni is
Brahma miss Hartigan embarrassed Ababa
throw hard to Hamdi I'm D so let me get
so he said hey baby
you look cute mm-hmm I'm hottest I'm
checking me out dad I just want to play
this little game we do cuz you look cute
looking for a quick [ __ ] yeah she's
everything you want us to go - okay are
you okay I'm nice and then if you go
Salameh how's he gonna collapse okay
eggsy okay her face isn't blurred for
pizzas they got exactly they're like
Chris just completely it's a complete
copy of Chris that's crazy well this is
kind of a brilliant play because it was
very successful here you transport it to
Israel and Bob's your uncle you're being
assassinated by conservative Israelis
how many of you does this home see
400,000 and lots of like let's all baby
that's a lot for his room its girl
that's like [ __ ] 50% of the
population isn't okay Sheikh got in that
was so slick here's the thing about in
Israel if you didn't know why she would
kissing like that Tellem you look you're
telling me that's right like you like
especially in Israel someone will just
kiss you that's what I'm saying more
like will slap you people are more
conservative more not great everything
they're more they don't say that you
don't touch me yeah
Israelis are hard people so the fact
that he's trying to get little kids in
Israel deals like people will die people
will die if low kids start doing this in
drill there's going to be a whole
bloodbath and that country is on thin
ice as it is we don't need all these
crisps prank invasion memes running
around Israel World War three I'm
telling you this is ground zero right
here are they even kissing the food
sorry you get tired yeah we get it
sad it's a sad day for but it's actually
doing really well sad day for you Israel
like it guys if you ever want to know
how to make a girl laugh here take a
look look I mean mcdoon in slow motion
this is important so we can study this
because kisses are all but in life that
matters if you can't get kisses then
your need to get out allocation now
watch closely
he's studying oh goes in quick lightly
touches her side bounces out point at
her give her kiss me Dom carmely ya
ain't down comb you've got to put the
hit on the shame on you
alright let's keep it going we're
getting close then I'm exhausted how
long we've been going almost three hours
oh we can end it let's keep going let's
finish the list okay guys
how y'all doing yellow are you okay
you seem tired mm-hmm Justin you gotta
help me out here and what are you are
doing I need some support you sitting
there you're Low Energy
how about soda pop I have a coffee hello
I need you jab I need to supply need
support here I'm low-energy Jeb can I do
okay well we can end it there's there's
so much more that I want to talk about
there's actually there's four more that
I want to talk about to be specific can
take a break and come back I guess we
could do it next time or take a break
this is turn into a complete nightmare
I'm glad this is at the end because
nobody gets this deep into the video
like maybe 5% we should just if you guys
if anyone watching this got this deep
into the episode just type something in
the comments so I could do a survey
something that no one ever typed like
Kermit the Frog Kermit the Frog titty
[ __ ] piggy type in the comments -
Kermit the Frog titty [ __ ] piggy on
YouTube
oh I want to know how many people
actually watch this beep if you're
Israeli type in Hebrew you don komedi
and your life kid just type his name
just I now know so all y'all I can't
wait for all those comments to be in the
and just completely to mystify everyone
else serve at the Frog clinic [ __ ] piggy
with like a thousand up hugs you never
just like why but we'll know we'll know
all right so I think this is it this I
mean yeah this is very much the end two
hours is a hard wall once you hit two
hours you a kind of downhill on the
energy levels now I'm at three hours and
now I'm just thinking about Kermit Eddie
[ __ ] piggy
are you also thinking about jello I'm
thinking about mixing some jello and
giving it to you I'm Kermit the Frog
should we well I have four more can we
save them for a very fun experiment for
next time let me see if these are
evergreen yeah these are evergreen so
I'll save these for next time all right
guys I hope you had a fun time this
episode thank you so much for joining us
mm-hmm was it was a holler thank you
everybody for supporting our sponsors
for subscribing to Amazon twitch Prime
or subscribing all together or donating
remember you can subscribe for free if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
look at the twitch give us a
subscription for free every month it's
huge it's amazing
so the joy it's been an honor to be here
with you guys may you find the private
jet the gods suggest into you to have so
you don't have to be in a long tube with
Devils a long day long you had those
guys said along to with Devils on
ironically people always come up to you
is just calling everyone and everyone
not only that he said people on the
airplanes are coming up asking me to
pray for them and then in the next
sentence she says in a tube with devils
who [ __ ] [ __ ] you
I want spamming by in the comments all
right you guys are the best thanks
everybody
appreciate you love you this was
shocking a month stay tuned bye dog
Kermit was it Kermit titty [ __ ] Pig you
already forgot yeah I'm tired you guys
will figure it out alright and dad bye
guys my